before I start I'm going to take a
vacation to a beautiful place called
someday I'll use proven success methods
problem unsolved is merely a goal
unachieved time management is the Sun
and everything that I do is the planets
in orbit point that's pretty obvious yes
but it's the most obvious answers that
we overlooked you become what you think
about most of the time and my natural
response uh Gandhi said be the change
you want to see in the world the rule is
form good habits and make them your
masters this year only as young or as
old as your dreams he's a motivational
speaker and author he's chairman SEO off
Brian Tracy International he's consulted
for over a thousand companies and
addressed more than 5 million people
he's spraying Tracy and here are his top
ten rules for success most people have
good great goals I want to increase my
income and lose weight and get out of
debt and be thin and happy and healthy
and have a wonderful family but then
then they decide but before I start I'm
going to take a vacation to a beautiful
place called
someday Isle and in my estimation eighty
percent of the population lives on some
day Isle
some day I'll lose some weight and some
day I'll read that book and listen to
that program and join the nest the S
network and there's some day I'll get
out of dead Sunday I'll increase my
income but it's always some day I'll if
you want to be a great success there's
one simple rule is vote yourself off the
island for life if you decide you're
going to do something do it you know
they've done dozens and dozens of
studies over the years they find that
there's one major difference between
successful people and unsuccessful
people as successful people launch they
start they get on with it they just do
it unsuccessful people get the same
ideas in the same information but
they've always got an excuse for not
starting if you want to be successful in
starting a business then you study what
people have learned and everything that
people have learned that written down or
shared in seminars or put onto audio
programs is I learned this from a very
wise man named cop cop
who spent more than 50 years studying
success and he had developed more than
1,000 success principles that he had
derived out of something like 6,000
books and when I met him I asked him the
question you would ask of all these
thousand principles because I had
studied it all which is the most
important principle of all and he said
Brian he said it's simple he said use
proven success methods he said learn
from the experts he said Brian you'll
never live long enough to learn it all
for yourself
so why find is that successful people
are those who learn from others who've
gone before them unsuccessful people try
to make it all up like a cook going into
the kitchen taking ingredients out of
the cupboards throwing them all in a
bowl and wondering why it doesn't taste
good this is why people sales careers
why 80% of sales people are functioning
well below their potential only 20% make
all the money by 20% of businesses in
any industry make all the profits by 20%
of the professionals in any service make
80% of the money and so on is because
they follow proven success principles
proven recipes proven formulas proven
combinations and they just do them over
and over again until they master them
then they can do more and more of them
faster and faster easier and easier at a
higher level of quality and all that
translates into greater results to make
a list of 10 things 10 goals that you
like to accomplish in the next year or
so and ask this question if I could only
accomplish one goal on this list which
one goal would have the greatest
positive impact on my life if you could
only accomplish one goal in life which
one goal would have the greatest
positive impact on your life now for
most people especially when you're
maturing in your career when you're
growing up the biggest goal is money if
you had money then you could buy a
household car family lifestyle and so on
so that's quite normal for other people
it may be a health goal for business
owners may be a business goal for people
with relationship problems may be a
relationship goal but ask yourself if
you could achieve one goal or resolve
one problem and remember a problem on
is merely a goal unachieved which one
would it be and write that down and make
that bat the major a definite purpose of
your life make it the central organizing
principle of your life when I was a
young man I had a revelation that
changed my life I had read articles and
sometimes books on time management over
the years and made some lists and set
some priorities and things like that and
I always felt however that my life was
the Sun and that all the different
factors of my life were like planets
that orbited around my life and whether
there was physical fitness or
socializing or work or time management
they were all planets in orbit what
changed my life is when I realized that
time management is the Sun and
everything that I do is the planets in
orbit everything we do in life revolves
around time because time is life is time
is the substance of our life is that the
quality of your life is determined by
the quality of your time management that
everything we have or are or ever will
be will be a direct result of how we use
our time and the wonderful thing is
we're always free to use choose how we
use our time there's a process which has
made more people rich than any other
single process of goals achieving and
it's to take your major goal and
structure it as a question if your goal
is to earn $100,000 a year then you
write how can I earn $100,000 in the
next 12 months
that's an open-ended question not how
can I earn it at my job or doing a
specific thing just an open-ended
question how can I earn the amount of
money and then you discipline yourself
to write 20 answers to the question and
the 20 answers are all the different
things that you could think of to earn a
hundred thousand dollars work a longer
work harder upgrade my skills get a new
job would take a part time opportunity
whatever it happens to be write down
everything you could think of but force
yourself to write at least 20 questions
or 20 answers to the question the 20
question method called mine stormy
forces you to dig deep deep into your
mind where you will find all your
answers and it may be call a person a
read a book
let me give you an example we had a
young fellow entrepreneur 35 years old
he built his successful business he
worked about 10 years to do it and he
for two years wanted to sell his
business so he could take a year off and
travel enjoy his money
and so for two years he just sort of
floundered around like a fish on the
dock wanting to sell his business nobody
offered to buy it he suggested it to
people people were not interested and so
on and in this exercise that they put
him through
he has xx answer and often it's xx
answer that is the breakthrough was buy
a book on how to sell your own business
and it just went off like a flashbulb in
his mind at the break he got up as a
downtown hotel got up went down to the
street to a major bookstore went and
found he was amazed at the number of
books had been written on how to buy and
sell a business so he bought two or
three books two months later he had
restructured packaged his business sold
it completely satisfactory and took a
year off he said it was just a single
idea it was a breakthrough idea but it
was so simple just get a book on the
subject and you think boy that's pretty
obvious yes but it's the most obvious
answers that we overlooked now the
starting point of becoming a millionaire
is to remember the greatest discovery of
all of human life which is that you
become what you think about most of the
time if you sincerely want to be rich to
achieve all your financial goals and to
retire as a self-made millionaire one of
the smartest things you can do is to
develop the habits of thinking and
acting that enabled others to become
self-made millionaires what is so hard
about this to understand most people are
thinking of how little money they have
they worry about being broke their we're
about lack and poverty they're worried
about the prices of everything and
they're wondering why they're not
flourishing financially because they're
thinking about poverty and lack rather
than prosperity and abundance now these
habits of financial success are learn
about as all habits are by practice and
repetition in other words you can
program yourself to think like self-made
millionaires and remember it has to
start on the inside before it ever comes
true on the outside
now here's an important point nothing
works the first time when you try
something new it probably won't work
when you try something new several times
it probably won't work and the turning
point in my life came when I would hear
good ideas and I was so eager to be
successful in selling I would run out
and try the ideas and they wouldn't work
I try a way of getting an appointment or
answering an objection or closing a sale
it wouldn't work and my natural response
ah and I think yes to be disappointed
and then I realized nothing works at
least the first few times so I decided I
would try a new idea five or ten times
before I pass judgment on I would not
just try it once and quit like most
people do and that changed my whole life
it was a turning point in my life
because I realized from then on if
you've got a good idea and you've got a
good goal and you want to double your
income and improve the quality of your
life and you have to try new things in
order to get new results it's not going
to work the first time so you say well
that didn't work try something else and
try something else and try something
else now if you try only two things can
happen what are they succeed or fail if
you succeed you do more of it if you
fail you learn from it get smarter and
try it again so you cannot lose by
taking action you can only lose by not
taking action
the natural tendency when we hear or
learn something great is we want to
convince everybody else of it all right
and you see this people who quit smoking
suddenly want there to be no smoking in
the world people who adopt a religion or
a political philosophy want everybody to
join the next day but the very best
thing as I mentioned earlier in our
seminar is that you must teach men at
the school of example before they will
learn at no other so what you need to do
is be an example and be an example for
an extended period of time
give yourself to three months maybe a
year of being the new person when you go
on a diet don't insist that everybody
else go on a diet the next day actually
go on the diet stay on the diet lose the
weight achieve the level of financial
fitness and attract people so they come
to you and say what is it that you're
doing or what is it that you're reading
or what is it that you have that makes
you different only then when they reach
out do offer to the flip side of this is
that in the main people don't change you
can change and
find it much easier to change of your
with positive people very hard to change
with people who don't want you to change
you want you to be the person that you
were but in the main people don't change
so sooner or later in life you're often
going to have to make some hard choices
in the short term be the person as as
Gandhi said be the change you want to
see in the world be the kind of person
that you want to see and if that does
not bring people around then be prepared
to go to the next step be prepared to
walk away
well Aristotle said that 95% of
everything you do is the result of habit
so the rule is form good habits and make
them your masters rather than allowing
bad habits to form in fact the other
rule says this is that good habits are
hard to form but easy to live with bad
habits are easy to form but hard to live
with now one of the turning points in my
life and my studies of psychology was
the discovery that all habits are
learned and can be unlearned actually
you don't actually unlearn a habit you
simply replace a bad habit with a good
habit that has more powerful power and
impact and how do you develop a good
habit you develop a habit by repetition
almost everything you do from the time
you get up in the morning is habit so
start to think about yourself what would
be the best habits to have good question
what age should one give up on their
dream never is good to said this Henry
Ford said this Rockefeller said this
you're only as young or as old as your
dreams and as long as you still have
dreams and visions and goals they keep
you young it's the most amazing darn
thing one of the great stories is the
story of Kentucky Fried Chicken once
it's gone upon a time there was a little
boy named Harlan and Harlan was taught
by his mother a special recipe down
south in the United States on how to
make chicken when he grew up he got a
job as a short-order cook in his small
cafe and he asked his boss if his boss
would be interested in this chicken
recipe and his boss said sure throw it
together see what the people say
turned out that everybody liked this
special chicken recipe with all these
secret herbs and spices well for the
rest of his career right up till he was
65 years old he either worked in little
cafes or sometimes he owned a little
cafe when he was 65 he had a little cafe
and he was making his chicken and he had
people coming from all around to eat his
chicken and the Highways Department
built a highway passed his little
restaurant his little chicken place and
put him out of business but cut off the
road so nobody could get to it but at
the same time he received a Social
Security check his first Social Security
check the age of 65 and he became angry
he said I'm 65 years old but I'm not
ready to give up on my dreams what do I
have to sell and he realized the one
thing that had kept him going all those
years the mainstay of his little career
was his mother's recipe of 17 or 18
herbs and spices so he put them together
in little bags one bag per chicken and
he put his pots and pans in the back of
his old car and he started driving up
and down the eastern seaboard going from
cafe to Cafe to cafe to ask them if they
would pay him five cents a bag for his
magical combination of herbs and spices
he called on more than 1,000 restaurants
sleeping in his car week after week and
finally he came across a little
restaurant in Toronto that agreed to pay
him five cents a bag for his herbs and
spices is back in the 60s and because of
exchange controls they had to give the
money to the Red Cross that was the
beginning of the Kentucky Fried Chicken
Empire we began to sell this recipe more
and more people began to put it on their
signs a major corporation came along and
said we could make a real business of
this so they embraced him they built the
franchise they made him one of the best
known people in the world when he died
some years later he was worth more than
50 million dollars because he never gave
up on his dreams so I don't know if
you're 65 and broke and living in your
car with pots and pans with no money but
wherever you are
you never give up on your dreams
thank you so much for watching we made
this video because fridge junior Jean
Baptiste asked us to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want us to profile
next leave it in the comments below I
will see what we can do and please let
us know which one of his top ten rules
that you liked the most
please leave a comment below we will
join in a discussion thank you guys for
watching continue to believe and we'll
see you soon
we say that in zero based thinking you
ask this question is there anything that
I am doing today that knowing what I now
know I wouldn't get into again today if
I had to do it over we call this a quick
analysis knowing what I now know quick
in times of rapid change there are
always areas in your personal and
business life that knowing what you now
know you wouldn't get into again today
if you had to do them over your
willingness to ask and honestly answer
this question is the key to remaining
flexible and quick on your feet in times
of turbulence how can you tell if you
have a zero based thinking situation in
your life or business simple stress
whenever you experience ongoing chronic
stress about any person or situation you
should ask yourself if I was not now in
this situation knowing what I now know
would I get into it again today this is
a great question
now here not the question for you what
percentage of the time do you think that
you will turn out to be wrong well the
answer according to the American
Management Association is about 70% 70%
of your decisions will turn out to be
wrong in the fullness of time it's
amazing how many people will stay in a
bad situation or continue with a bad
course of action because of their
unwillingness or inability to admit that
they made a mistake or that they were
wrong in the past but remember this when
you made the decision it was probably a
good decision
based on the situation at that time but
now the situation has changed now you
have to evaluate your situation based on
the current reality recognize that
everything that you achieve in life is
going to be with the help or support or
cooperation of other people so always
think what is it that other people want
and need from me how can I help other
people so they'll want to help me back
if you're in sales drop sales people
think about their customers all the time
they think about who their customers are
and what their customers want and how
they can help them the most and how they
can help them even more today in their
relationships successful people are very
focused on the most important people in
their worlds both personal and in
business if you have made a mistake or
something has happened in the past
that's unfortunate you can cancel it out
by simply saying the magic words
I am responsible I am responsible I am
responsible if someone has hurt you or
you've had a difficult experience in
your childhood you can say well I didn't
do anything yes but you're responsible
for how you respond today a Nobel
prize-winning study of the evolution of
civilizations came up with the term
response ability is your ability to
respond effectively with the ups and
downs and negative events of life is the
key measure of your ability to be
successful and happy in the future and
the what you do is you say whenever you
feel negative or unhappy about anything
you say wait a minute I'm responsible
I'm responsible for my life I'm
responsible for what happens I can't
change the past so I'm not going to
spend a second worrying about the past
I'm going to become so busy working on
my future and my goals that I don't have
time to think about the past